I'd now like to introduce Ian Glasner
president of the student body ian is
graduating today with a double major in
electrical and computer engineering and
business please join me in welcoming him
challenge if I could describe my
Carnegie Mellon experience in one word
it would be challenged when I say
challenge I'm not simply talking about
the first computer engineering exam I
took freshman year I am actually more so
referring to the subsequent phone call I
had to give my mom telling her that I
failed things didn't exactly start off
as planned at the time it felt like
Carnegie Mellon had completely knocked
me over but we've all learned things
here like that a 0% chance of rain
really means the weather forecaster is
just hoping it doesn't rain those days
usually end with muddy shoes in a
soaking wet backpack or that counting on
a Pittsburgh bus to show up on time is a
great way to be very very late by
knocking us over Carnegie Mellon has
taught us how to get back up and
sometimes getting back up involves
drinking a redbull or several cups of
coffee in the basement of hunt library
alone at two a.m. on a saturday
we've all been there we've all learned I
hope everyone brought an umbrella today
everyone here today has hit a bump in
the last four years and we've all gotten
back up after CMU has been a challenge
but class of 2015 we made it look around
in less than 90 minutes we will all be
graduates of Carnegie Mellon University
today I would like to share with you the
first of many incredible achievements I
hope that our class will have as alumni
the Board of Trustees challenged our
class to make a senior gift to campus
something similar to the class of
nineteen eighty eighty seven room in the
cowan university center but it's easier
said than done asking college students
to make a donation as a tough sell
considering many of us have borderline
or not so borderline negative bank
accounts the class of 2013 gave it a
rate of six percent and last year's
seniors gave at a rate of fifteen
percent today I'd like to announce that
more than four hundred and thirty two
members of our class contributed that's
well over thirty percent
it's more than double last year and it's
an all-time record for Carnegie Mellon
in a few days we will be spread out
across the country and the world just
like we were four years ago let's not
make this the last time we are all in
Pittsburgh together 5 10 50 years down
the road remember Carnegie Mellon
University remember where you learned
how to get back up and keep going so
long class of 2015 may your futures be
bright and your hearts forever in the
work that we all did here together thank
you